located very nicely by the bishop and uh  it must be now ding who has the winning  chances with more dangerous past pawns  that's often what it comes down to in  the ending who's got the more dangerous  past pawns and uh  well okay it's not over yet by any means  but  he's blunted he forgot his knight could  be captured and it's a pawn race both  sides are going to make queens  but black has an extra bishop and  that's heartbreaking heartbreaking  yeah that's where he's going to queen  first and then it's going to be checked  and yeah oh no  i think it's maybe this position he  thought he was queening but black's  bishop next is going to give a check and  there we go white king is forced onto a  square where it will be checked and came  over  so heartbreaking he played so well